I finally ordered one of these dresses,
like corset high up dresses,
and I am in love. I didn't realize that there is a zipper on the side,
and it is very, very stretchy.
So I would size down a little bit if you like that kind of,
you know, feeling.
I like how far apart the straps are sometimes.
I don't like when they're, like,
too close. I feel like it's not as cute.
I love the, like,
wider straps. They're very,
very stretchy, too.
It ties up right here,
so you can make this part as tight or as loose as you like.
In the back.
It's like a lace up type thing,
but it's lined in the back with black fabric,
so it's not like you have to show your back or anything,
which I really like as well.
I have a slit, but it isn't super high.
I like a slit, but I don't like when they're too high.
Wanna keep it classy.
I couldn't decide between the black or the light blue,
and now that I know how amazing the material is,
I'm definitely gonna go back and have to order the blue.
Sure to check if you have any coupons,
because TikTok Shop likes to just give out random coupons
and they'll save you a bunch of money.
Let me know if you order it and what color you get.